Speaking of psychology is taking a short winter break, so we're revisiting one of our favorite episodes from the past year. In May, we talked to Dr. Michael Yasser from the University of California, Irvine about his research on highly superior autobiographical memory, the remarkable ability that some people have to remember nearly every day of their life. Markey Pasternak, a woman with H. Sam, as it's known, also joined us to discuss what it's like to live with H. Sam and how her memory works. I hope you enjoy this episode from our archives. Speaking of psychology, we'll be back in January with new weekly episodes. Thank you for listening. Do you remember where you were on April 10, 1999? What day of the week was it? What about the weather? What were you wearing? And what did you do all day? Chances are you can't answer any of those questions.
Speaking of Psychology 目前正在进行短暂的寒冬休假，因此我们将重新回顾过去一年中我们最喜欢的几期节目之一。在 5 月份，我们采访了加州大学欧文分校的迈克尔·亚萨 (Michael Yassa) 博士，探讨了他关于高度优势自传体记忆的研究。这是一种非凡的能力，某些人能够记住他们一生的几乎每一天。拥用这种被称为 H-SAM 能力的女性马基·帕斯特纳克 (Markey Pasternak) 也加入了我们，探讨与 H-SAM 一起生活是怎样的感受以及她的记忆是如何运作的。希望你喜欢我们档案库里的这期节目。Speaking of Psychology 将于 1 月带着全新的每周节目回归。感谢您的收听。你还记得 1999 年 4 月 10 日你在哪里吗？那天是星期几？天气怎么样？你穿着什么？你一整天都在做什么？你大概无法回答这些问题中的任何一个。
For most of us, our autobiographical memory is a bit of a blur. Sure, some special occasions stand out, weddings, birthdays, vacations, along with a bundle of random memories that stick with us for no special reason. But for people with highly superior autobiographical memory, or H. Sam, every day is memorable. Ask someone with H. Sam what they were doing on April 10, 1999, or the 11th, or the 16th, and they'll be able to tell you, along with a bunch of other checkable facts. How do they do that? How do the brains of people with H. Sam store and retrieve this vast amount of detailed autobiographical information? What's it like to be able to remember every day of your life? Is it a blessing or a curse? And what can studying this unusual ability teach us about how
对于我们大多数人来说，我们的自传体记忆有点模糊。当然，一些特殊的场合会脱颖而出，婚礼、生日、假期，还有一堆随机的记忆，无缘无故地留在我们心中。但是对于拥有高度优势自传体记忆（或称 H-SAM）的人来说，每一天都是难忘的。问一个拥有 H-SAM 的人他们在 1999 年 4 月 10 日、11 日或 16 日在做什么，他们将能够告诉你，连同一堆其他可核对的事实。他们是怎么做到的？拥有 H-SAM 的人的大脑是如何存储和检索如此大量的详细自传体信息的？能够记住你生命的每一天是什么感觉？这是一份祝福还是一个诅咒？研究这种不寻常的能力能教给我们关于
memory works for the rest of us? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mill. We have two guests today. Dr. Michael Yasser is the director of the Center for the Neurobiology of Learning and Memory at the University of California, Irvine. The center was established in 1983 by Dr. James McGough, and it's where the first research on highly superior autobiographical memory began about 15 years ago. Today, Dr. Yasser and his colleagues continue to study H-SAM, along with how we learn and remember information, how learning and memory change with age,
其余人的记忆是如何运作的？欢迎来到 Speaking of Psychology，这是美国心理学协会的旗舰播客，探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯 (Kim Mills)。我们今天有两位嘉宾。迈克尔·亚萨博士是加州大学欧文分校学习与记忆神经生物学中心的主任。该中心由詹姆斯·麦高 (James McGough) 博士于 1983 年建立，大约 15 年前，关于高度优势自传体记忆的第一批研究正是在这里开始的。今天，亚萨博士和他的同事们继续研究 H-SAM，以及我们如何学习和记忆信息、学习和记忆如何随年龄增长而变化，
and how to better diagnose and treat disorders like Alzheimer's disease. Our second guest is Markey Pastornak, one of the few people in the world confirmed to have H-SAM. In 2014, when she was a junior in college, Ms. Pasternak learned about highly superior autobiographical memory in one of her psychology courses,
以及如何更好地诊断和治疗阿尔茨海默病等疾病。我们的第二位嘉宾是马基·帕斯特纳克，她是世界上极少数被确认拥有 H-SAM 的人之一。2014 年，当她上大学三年级时，帕斯特纳克女士在一门心理学课程中了解到了高度优势自传体记忆，
realized that it described her special memory, and began participating in research at UC Irvine. She went on to earn a master's degree in education, and today works in student affairs at Auburn University, doing mental wellness and health education outreach. She also blogs and speaks to the media about living with H. Sam. Thank you both for joining us today. Thank you for having me. Yes, thank you so much for having us.
意识到它描述了她的特殊记忆，并开始参与加州大学欧文分校的研究。她后来获得了教育学硕士学位，今天在奥本大学的学生事务部门工作，从事心理健康和健康教育外展服务。她还写博客并向媒体讲述与 H-SAM 一起生活的故事。非常感谢两位今天加入我们。谢谢你们邀请我。是的，非常感谢你们邀请我们。
Dr. Yasser, you get the first questions. When people with H. Sam retrieve autobiographical memories, are they doing the same thing that most of us do when we remember our past, but they're just much better at it than the rest of us? You know, you started with a very difficult question, Kim. I think this is really what we're trying to get to the bottom of. And part of the problem is that when we were first kind of exposed to this phenomenon, it violated all of our assumptions about how memory works. So one of the first thoughts was, well, they must be using a different mechanism.
亚萨博士，您先回答第一个问题。当拥有 H-SAM 的人检索自传体记忆时，他们是在做我们大多数人在回忆过去时所做的事情，只是他们比我们其他人做得好得多吗？你知道，你以一个非常困难的问题开头，金。我认为这确实是我们试图弄清楚的根本。部分问题在于，当我们第一次接触到这种现象时，它违反了我们对记忆运作方式的所有假设。因此，最早的想法之一是，好吧，他们一定使用了不同的机制。
But push to the extreme, one can imagine that, you know, our regular memory systems just have a degree of variation in them that it could be part of the regular mechanisms, just like I said, pushed to the extreme. And we're still not sure if they're part of that natural variation or if they're using very distinct mechanisms. And that's what we're hoping to uncover in the coming years with some brain imaging techniques and various other methods that look deep into the neurobiology of the brain.
但推向极致，人们可以想象，你知道，我们的常规记忆系统本身就存在一定程度的变化，它可能只是常规机制的一部分，就像我说的，被推到了极致。我们仍然不确定它们是这种自然变异的一部分，还是使用了非常独特的机制。这就是我们希望在未来几年通过一些大脑成像技术和深入研究大脑神经生物学的各种其他方法来揭开的面纱。
Markey, can you talk about how this works for you when you remember a particular day from 10 years ago? what are you doing? Does the memory just pop up or do you have to work to retrieve it? So it kind of depends on the day. I was actually talking to a psychology professor at Auburn about this about a year ago because it's fun working at universities, right? Because the psychology departments get real excited. And what I told him is I, and we kind of coined them, I have these things called go-to dates, right? Dates that just stick in my memory because of an event that happened that maybe had more of an emotional connection to it. So for example, I know like sad example to start off with, But if you ask me the day my father died, right? I'd be like March 16th, 2014, and most people could probably do that. But then I also can remember, you know, the day I saw a boy I had a crush on in the seventh grade for the first time in a while. And that was June 26, 2007.
马基，你能谈谈当你回忆 10 年前的某一天时，这对你来说是如何运作的吗？你在做什么？记忆是突然浮现的，还是你必须努力去检索它？所以这有点取决于那天。大约一年前，我实际上在和奥本大学的一位心理学教授谈论这件事，因为在大学工作很有趣，对吧？因为心理学系真的很兴奋。我告诉他的是，我们把它们创造出来，我有一些叫做“首选日期”的东西，对吧？由于发生了一起可能具有更多情感联系的事件，这些日期只留在我的记忆中。例如，我知道这是一个悲伤的开头例子，但如果你问我父亲去世的那天，对吧？我会说是 2014 年 3 月 16 日，大多数人可能都能做到这一点。但随后我也能记住，你知道我很久以来第一次在七年级看到一个我暗恋的男孩的那天。那是 2007 年 6 月 26 日。
It was a Tuesday. And I could tell you all about that, right? So, like, they can get, you have more random days that you hold with these things. But, you know, if I can go real back to, let's say go that 2007 date, right? if I can go back and say, yeah, I saw this guy, you know, at the ice rink because I was a figure skater and he was a hockey player and I like bumped into him there and I can tell you all about that. I can also piece around the days around it. And that's where the memory kind of starts coming into fruition. And so I can say, oh, I went to that ice skating practice that day,
那是星期二。我可以告诉你所有关于那件事的信息，对吧？所以，就像，他们可以得到，你保留这些东西的更随机的日子。但是，你知道，如果我能回到过去，比如说回到 2007 年的那个日期，对吧？如果我能回去说，是的，我在溜冰场看到了这个家伙，因为我是一名花样滑冰运动员，而他是一名曲棍球运动员，我在那里撞到了他，我可以告诉你所有关于那件事的信息。我也可以把周围的日子拼凑起来。这就是记忆开始实现的地方。所以我可以说，哦，那天我去参加了花样滑冰练习，
even though I didn't usually skate on Tuesday nights over the summer, because I had stayed with another friend on my figure skating team that day. And it was her birthday, um, in a couple days. And so I was spending time with her because it had just been our birthday party the day before. So I can like that context kind of comes in and I can start piecing around it. So sometimes if you ask me like a date, I might be like, oh wait, I don't know exactly what I did on that day quite yet, but I can go to my nearest go to date, put the context together and kind of crawl to it. And it's like a mental image for me. And I know this is different, different people with H Sam.
尽管我夏天通常不在周二晚上滑冰，因为那天我和花样滑冰队的另一个朋友呆在一起。再过几天就是她的生日了。所以我花时间陪她，因为前一天刚举办了我们的生日派对。所以就像这种背景进来了，我可以开始围绕它拼凑。所以有时如果你问我一个日期，我可能会想，哦等等，我还不完全知道我在那天做了什么，但我可以去我最近的首选日期，把背景放在一起，然后有点爬过去。这对我来说就像是一个心理图像。我知道这对于拥有 H-SAM 的不同人来说是不同的。
I know I've talked to some friends with H. Sam who say they just picture like a calendar, like a black and white regular calendar. That's not me. I have some synesthesia as well. So for me, what it looks like is it's like a giant like Candy Land Board sort of a thing. I think of it or like a giant map or like a road with a journey. It's all different colors and there's dates everywhere and there's like people and images and places and it's like this fun place in my brain I can kind of go to and like hop around
我知道我曾与一些拥有 H-SAM 的朋友交谈过，他们说他们只是想象着像日历一样的东西，就像一本黑白的普通日历。我不是那样的。我也有一些联觉。所以对我有用的是，它看起来就像一个巨大的“糖果乐园”棋盘一样的东西。我想象它就像一张巨大的地图或一条充满旅程的道路。到处都是不同的颜色，到处都是日期，还有人和图像和地方，这就像我大脑中的一个有趣的地方，我可以去那里四处跳跃
and different days and I can like zoom in on the days and the years and all in the times and all that stuff. That sounds amazing. Well, Markey, when did you first realize that your memory was different from that of other people? How old were you? And what triggered that realization? Yeah. So I'm going to be honest. I feel like sometimes when I answer this question, I feel like it's supposed to be an aha moment, right? Like this big, like, oh my gosh, my brain's different. But the reality is, is that it was just a series of little moments that added to the realization over a lot of years because it's so unique and kind of difficult to figure out, especially when it's happening to use a kid, you know, and you don't really have all the vocabulary to describe what's going on. And so the first time
不同的日子，我可以放大日子、年份、时间和所有这些东西。听起来太棒了。马基，你是什么时候第一次意识到你的记忆与其他人不同的？你多大了？是什么引发了这种认识？是的。所以我要诚实。我觉得有时当我回答这个问题时，我觉得它应该是一个“啊哈”时刻，对吧？就像那种巨大的，“哦天哪，我的大脑与众不同”的感觉。但现实是，这只是一系列小时刻，经过多年积累才有了这种认识，因为它是如此独特，而且很难弄清楚，尤其是当它发生在你还是个孩子的时候，你知道，你并没有真正掌握所有的词汇来描述发生了什么。所以第一次
I noticed it was different was probably in 2006. I was, I had just turned 12 years old. And I started realizing I could remember what I was doing a year ago every day. Like I was like, oh, it's, you know, May 11th, like a year ago was our band concert. And then we left for Florida the next day. But like, no one else really cared to remember that our band concert was a year ago that day. But for some reason, I just knew. And like, I remember being like, I should check, like, what's happening? I should check this out. So I went to the home video and there it was like, you know, May 11th, 2005. And I was like, I was like, okay. And so I started realizing it then. And then as the years went on, I realized I could keep doing it. Like it wasn't just, I had a good memory for 2005, 2006 stuck, 2007 stuck,
我注意到它不同大概是在 2006 年。我当时，我刚刚满 12 岁。我开始意识到我可以记住一年前每一天我在做什么。就像我一样，哦，是，你知道，5 月 11 日，一年前是我们的乐队音乐会。然后我们第二天出发去佛罗里达。但是，没有其他人真正关心记住我们的乐队音乐会正好是一年前的那天。但出于某种原因，我就是知道。并且，我记得当时想，我应该检查一下，发生了什么？我应该查证一下。所以我看了家庭录像带，它就在那里，你知道，2005 年 5 月 11 日。我想，我就这样。所以我当时开始意识到这一点。然后随着时间的推移，我意识到我可以继续做到这一点。就像不仅仅是，我对 2005 年有很好的记忆，2006 年留下了，2007 年留下了，
2008 stuck. And so when I was in eighth grade, I really got obsessed with like memories and old pictures and dates and things like that. And it was just becoming something that was kind of crystallizing in my brain more. And I realized that the first, like, week I could remember was the week of February 9th through the 13th of 2005. And the 9th was a Wednesday. And everything just kind of starts on that Wednesday. And then the next days are real vivid. And then, like, the next week or two is kind of blurry. But then after that, everything is really vivid. And I was like, you know, do I have those dates right? And so I remember I was, I had a figure skating competition as I was talking about figure skating earlier that weekend in a place called Beaver Dam, Wisconsin, or is my father like to call
2008 年留下了。所以当我上八年级时，我真的很着迷于记忆、旧照片、日期和诸如此类的事情。这正在成为一种在我大脑中更加结晶的事情。我意识到我能记住的第一周是 2005 年 2 月 9 日到 13 日的那一周。第九天是星期三。一切都从那个星期三开始。然后接下来的几天非常生动。然后，接下来的一个或两个星期有点模糊。但那之后，一切都非常生动。我想，你知道，我把这些日期记对了吗？所以我记得我，我有一个花样滑冰比赛，就像我之前谈到的那样，在威斯康星州一个叫海狸坝 (Beaver Dam) 的地方，或者就像我父亲喜欢称呼的那样
it Beaver Darn? And I went in the basement and I dug through my mom's like totes of like old memorabilia and scrapbooking stuff. And I found the brochure from that competition. And it said February 13th, 2005. And I was like, all right, I have something here. So that was kind of the realization of it is a kid. Wow. There are 7.9 billion people in the world today, give or take a few thousand. Dr. Yassa, how many people have been confirmed to have H. Sam? And how do you find these people? Another tricky question, Kim.
叫海狸诅咒 (Beaver Darn)？我去了地下室，翻找了我妈妈装满旧纪念品和剪贴簿东西的塑料箱。我找到了那场比赛的手册。上面写着 2005 年 2 月 13 日。我想，好吧，我这里有东西。所以这可以说是作为一个孩子对它的认识。哇。当今世界有 79 亿人口，上下浮动几千人。亚萨博士，有多少人被证实拥有 H-SAM？你是如何找到这些人的？又是一个棘手的问题，金。
So I'll give you the answer that we have, but there's a caveat, right? So we have identified, it's smaller than 100 that we have identified in the laboratory. But we are also getting reports from our colleagues actually around the world in different countries. of also having individuals kind of come to them and say, I have this extremely vivid memory in the past. And they may not have seen a 60-minute piece or read about it in a book or a paper, but just sort of think it's curious.
所以我会给你我们拥有的答案，但有一个告诫，对吧？所以我们已经确定了，我们在实验室中确定的人数不到 100 人。但我们也收到了来自世界各地不同国家的同事的报告，称也有个体来到他们面前说，我在过去有这种极其生动的记忆。他们可能没有看过“60分钟”的节目，也没有在书本或论文中读到过它，只是觉得很好奇。
But that's really the issue, is that until maybe Markey has gone through this exercise and really confirmed it, or somebody has seen a piece on 60 minutes or read a paper or heard about it in a class, class, it's really difficult to see this as something different from everybody else. So my guess is that actually there's a lot of people out there that have it and just don't know and have no reason to suspect that it's all that different.
但真正的问题在于，直到马基经历了这个过程并真正确认了它，或者有人在“60分钟”节目中看过相关报道，或者读过一篇论文，或在课堂上听说过它，否则很难将这视为与其他人不同的东西。所以我的猜测是，实际上有很多人拥有它，只是不知道也没有理由怀疑它有什么不同。
They may just be on the extreme. They might think of themselves as having really good memory, but they may not think of it as a unique condition. And they might look at others around them and think, well, why does everybody else have really crappy memory, you know, as opposed to them sort of being the unique ones? So I think we're probably underestimating the number of folks who have it. I don't think it's limited to 100. I think it's more likely to be in the thousands, which still makes it a unique enough condition.
他们可能只是处于极端。他们可能认为自己记忆力非常好，但可能不认为这是一种独特的病症。他们可能会看着周围的人，心想，为什么其他人的记忆力都这么糟糕，而不是认为自己是独一无二的那个人。所以我想我们可能低估了拥有它的人数。我不认为它仅限于 100 人。我认为更有可能达到数千人，这仍然使其成为一种足够独特的病症。
But we have to have a better means to get those numbers. What are the tests like when you're trying to confirm that somebody actually has it? Yeah, so you've gone through this already, Marky. And here's the problem with the tests, is that the initial phase of the test, testing was really based on sort of almanac type knowledge. Let's pick on something that is can have a veridical record that could be confirmed. So public events, things that, you know, it's very clear what the actual answers are. But it turned out as we, and we were able to identify a lot of people that way. But it turned out as, as time went on, you recognize that there are folks who just, this may
但我们需要有更好的方法来获取这些数字。当你试图确认某人确实拥有它时，测试是什么样的？是的，所以你已经经历过这个了，马基。这就是测试的问题所在，测试的初始阶段，测试 realmente 基于某种年鉴类型的知识。让我们挑一些可以有真实记录、可以被证实的。所以公共事件，那些，你知道，实际答案非常清楚的事情。但事实证明，当我们，我们能够通过这种方式识别出很多人。但事实证明，随着时间的推移，你会发现有些人只是，这可能
not be their area of expertise. They may not be very attuned to celebrities in particular, you know, public events, but they have incredibly good autobiographical memory. So how do you derive a test that is sensitive to those variations and expertise? And in fact, that's work that's ongoing in our lab right now. We're trying to devise a more individualized approach that takes the categories of expertise of the individual and then selects the questions for the tool based on the areas that they have selected in a pre-test to say, those are the things I'm comfortable with. Those are the areas where I think I have a lot of knowledge that are related to my autobiography. I was a big TV buff when I was growing up.
不是他们的专业领域。他们可能对名人特别是名人（公共事件）不是很敏感，但他们拥有令人难以置信的自传体记忆。那么，如何设计一个对这些差异和专业知识敏感的测试呢？事实上，这是我们实验室目前正在进行的工作。我们正试图设计一种更加个性化的方法，采用个人的专业知识类别，然后根据他们在预测试中选择的领域为工具选择问题，并说：“这些是我觉得舒服的事情。这些是我认为自己拥有大量与我的自传相关的知识的领域。我在成长过程中是一个狂热的电视迷。”
I love sports, you know, whatever it may be. And then we can be a little bit more sensitive to their special abilities in those kinds of domains. Do people with H-SAM have above-average memories in general, like for facts and figures and non-autobiographical knowledge? That's the part that's really, really interesting. Not at all. So it really is just autobiographical. I know, Marky's making that.
我喜欢体育运动，无论它是什么。然后我们可以对他们在这些领域的特殊能力更加敏感。拥有 H-SAM 的人通常有高于平均水平的记忆力吗，比如对于事实、数字和非自传体知识？这才是真正非常非常有趣的部分。一点也没有。所以它确实只是自传体的。我知道，马基在做那个
expression that suggests that you wish it was better for everything else. And I think that's the reaction we hear from most people. You know, they weren't maybe all that exceptional in terms of their school. It's not like they could memorize all Shakespeare and all of these things. You know, their memorization is really just average. And if you test them on standardized memory tests, you know, word list, recall and things like that, it's really just average. It seems to be highly specialized for the person's own narrative,
表情，这表明你希望其他所有事情都变得更好。我认为这是我们从大多数人那里听到的反应。你知道，他们在学校方面可能并没有那么出色。这并不是说他们可以背诵所有的莎士比亚和所有这些东西。你知道，他们的记忆力真的只是平均水平。如果你在标准化的记忆测试（单词列表、回忆等）上测试他们，它真的只是平均水平。它似乎高度专业化于个人自己的叙事，
for their own autobiographical memories and events, things that have happened to them and other things that are related to that narrative. So if, say, you're studying French in school and you have H-SAM, does that mean that you're going to have better memory for vocabulary and verb conjugations, for example? Not at all. Unless you can figure out a way to make French really be part of your autobiographical narrative. So if it's, you know, if you've traveled to France and spent time there, it became sort of part of your background and autobiography that I think that that's a possibility. But
为了他们自己的自传体记忆和事件，发生在他身上的事情以及与该叙事相关的其他事情。所以，如果，比如说，你在学校学习法语，并且你拥有 H-SAM，这是否意味着你对词汇和动词变位会有更好的记忆？一点也没有。除非你能想出一种方法，让法语真正成为你自传叙事的一部分。所以如果它是，你知道，如果你去过法国并在那里度过了一段时间，它就成为了你的背景和自传的一部分，我认为这是一种可能性。但是
just naturally taking it in class, I think the reaction is the same one that you get from everybody else. I'm not going to remember much until I practice it. Marky, what was it like to take the test to confirm that you actually have this? I love this question because not a lot of people ask it. So that's what's cool about being on this podcast in particular. You know, I was nervous. I was really nervous because for me, the stakes were high. The stakes for me taking this test were if I don't, if they asked dates and events that I don't get right, I'm going to be excluded from this group of people that I know I belong to. And that could give me some sort of solidarity in a community where I feel isolated in a lot of the world because of my memory. So I was really nervous,
只是自然地在课堂上接受它，我认为反应和你在其他人那里得到的反应是一样的。除非我练习，否则我记不住太多。马基，参加测试以确认你确实拥有这个是什么感觉？我喜欢这个问题，因为没有多少人问它。这就是参加这个特定播客的酷炫之处。你知道，我很紧张。我真的很紧张，因为对我来说，风险很高。我参加这个测试的风险是，如果我做不到，如果他们问我不对的日期和事件，我将被排除在这个我知道我属于的人群之外。这可以给我提供某种社区内的团结感，因为我的记忆力，我在世界很多地方感到孤立。所以我真的很紧张，
you know. And so I was a junior in college at Marquette University. I had just learned the previous semester about H. Sam in a class like you had said in the introduction. And my professor was confident I had it. Like she was a neuroscientist and a neuroscience professor studying Alzheimer's opposite of what was going on with me. And she, you know, she knew a lot. She had done her postdoc at UC Irvine and knew a lot of the folks over there and was like, you have. You have. these are the people you need to talk to. Yes, exactly. And so I did the test over the phone.
你知道。所以我当时是马凯特大学的大学三年级学生。就像你在介绍中说的那样，我在一门课程中刚刚在前一个学期了解了 H-SAM。我的教授确信我有。就像她是一位神经科学家和神经科学教授，研究与我身上发生的事情相反的阿尔茨海默病。并且她，你知道，她知道很多。她曾在加州大学欧文分校做过博士后，认识很多那里的人，并说：“你有。你有。这些人就是你需要交谈的人。”是的，没错。所以我通过电话进行了测试。
And I believe my first test was on March 1st of 2015. And what had happened was my friends actually helped me like kind of practice a little bit. So what they did was they would throw me like for the week before like current events randomly. I'd be like studying for a test. And they'd be like, what was the Sandy Hook shooting? I'd be like December 14th, 2012. And like, you know, just so I get my brain in that kind of like, in that mode of like, I can do it quick. Because I can do it if you allow me enough time.
我相信我的第一次测试是在 2015 年 3 月 1 日。发生的事情是我的朋友们实际上帮我练习了一点。所以他们做的是，在当前事件前的一周里，他们会随机向我抛出问题。我会在复习考试。他们会问：“桑迪·胡克枪击案是什么时候？”我会说：“2012 年 12 月 14 日。”并且，就像，你知道，只是为了让我的大脑进入那种模式，我可以快速做到这一点。因为如果你给我足够的时间，我能做到。
But, you know, I didn't know how long these researchers were willing to give me to answer the questions. And so I had some nice collaborative roommates and friends on campus who were like, we know you have this. We're going to help you. We got this. You know. And the test ended up going well. but to kind of jump on what Dr. Yasa was saying as well is that it's a really difficult thing to test because I was one of the youngest people they had ever tested at the time back in 2015. So they were asking a lot of questions that were not relevant to me and they were not in my time frame.
但是，你知道，我不知道这些研究人员愿意给我多长时间来回答问题。所以我有一些很好的室友和校园里的朋友，他们说：“我们知道你有这个。我们要帮你。我们搞得定。你知道的。”测试结果最终很好。但是为了顺应亚萨博士刚才所说的话，这也是一件很难测试的事情，因为在 2015 年当时，我是他们测试过的最年轻的人之一。所以他们问了很多与我无关且不在我的时间范围内的问。
So if they asked me, you know, gosh, I'm just trying to think, you know, when the Oscars were in 97, I didn't know that because I was three years old and I did not care about the Oscars. but I didn't want that to be a point against me. So they had to like ask me, you know, different questions. And I think that's the another part part about testing H-SAM is that you've got these age groups who can remember different things at different times. So it's not only the interests, but it's the ages because even if I can remember in 2005 and there's like a political event that took place, a fifth grader doesn't care. And probably if I was, you know, I was privileged enough to probably not even have to care at the time. if it didn't affect my population. And so that can be, I think, really difficult, too.
所以如果他们问我，天哪，我只是在想，你知道，1997 年奥斯卡颁奖典礼是什么时候，我不知道，因为我当时三岁，我根本不在乎奥斯卡。但我不想这成为对我不利的一点。所以他们不得不问我，你知道，不同的问题。我认为这是测试 H-SAM 的另一个部分，那就是你有这些不同年龄组的人可以在不同时间记住不同的事情。所以不仅是兴趣，还有年龄，因为即使我能记住 2005 年发生了一个政治事件，五年级的学生也不会在意。可能如果我是，你知道，我有幸甚至不必在当时关心，如果它没有影响我的群体。我认为这也会非常困难。
And that's what we ran into in the testing a lot was like, there are just some events that they had asked that were in my time frame, but I didn't hear about, you know, in sixth grade. But they were able to do some replacements. It sounds a little bit like you were studying to go on Jeopardy. Yeah, a little bit, a little bit. But just like, again, getting my brain in that mode, because I knew I could do it.
这正是我们在测试中经常遇到的情况，就像有些事件是他们问的，在我的时间范围内，但在六年级时我没有听说过。但他们能够做一些替换。听起来有点像你在准备去参加《危险边缘》(Jeopardy) 游戏节目。是的，有点，有点。但就像，再次让我的大脑进入那个模式，因为我知道我能做到。
I wasn't like memorizing dates or anything. It was just kind of getting in that like recall mode where I could go kind of fast with it. So there was that, you know. Dr. Yasser, what do we know about the causes of H-Sam? Is there a genetic component to it or any other hints about the etiology? Yeah. So we're trying to get to the bottom of the potential heritability. So we don't think it's a direct genetic component as in if somebody has it, they're going to pass it on.
我不是在背诵日期或任何东西。它只是有点进入那种回忆模式，我可以很快地处理它。所以有那样，你知道的。亚萨博士，我们对 H-SAM 的成因了解多少？它有遗传成分吗，或者关于病因学的其他任何线索？是的。所以我们正试图弄清楚潜在的遗传度。所以我们不认为这是一个直接的遗传成分，好像如果有人拥有它，他们就会把它传给
to their children. But interestingly, in some of the cases, it turns out that there's also kind of extended family, relatives, cousins, maybe who have some traces of it as well. So it's a complex heritability pattern, if there is one. And we're working with some colleagues who are really exceptional in terms of working on genetics to try to reveal the basis of this. Interestingly, one thing that might give us some clues is a set of identical twins, and one of them has it, the other one does not. So it automatically tells us that it cannot be genetically inherited directly, because otherwise they would share that.
他们的孩子。但有趣的是，在某些情况下，事实证明也存在某种大家庭、亲戚、表亲，他们也可能有一些痕迹。所以这是一个复杂的遗传模式，如果真的有的话。我们正在与一些在遗传学研究方面非常出色的同事合作，试图揭示这一基础。有趣的是，有一件事可能会给我们一些线索，那就是一对同卵双胞胎，其中一个有，另一个没有。所以它自动告诉我们它不能直接遗传，否则他们会分享这一点。
But there may be something that happens after the original splitting of that DNA that might be different, and we're trying to get to the bottom of that. But it is complicated because we don't have a huge sample to test. And certainly, even within that smaller sample, the number of folks where there might be a trace of heritability is even smaller. So it's not entirely clear how much of it is heritable and how much of it is environmental. With respect to the onset, it does vary from individual to individual. Usually there's sort of a precipitating period or event. usually it's during adolescence where that kind of comes to fully to fruition.
但该 DNA 最初分裂后可能会发生一些不同的事情，我们正试图弄清楚这一点。但这很复杂，因为我们没有庞大的样本来测试。当然，即使在那个较小的样本中，可能存在遗传痕迹的人数甚至更少。所以完全不清楚有多少是遗传的，有多少是环境的。关于发作年龄，它因人而异。通常有一个诱发期或事件。通常是在青春期，这种能力才完全成熟。
And it may be sort of the first person's first realization that this is what's going on. Or it may be that memories start to get really, really strong after a particular event that could be a big change. It's possible that it's traumatic. It's possible that it's just a kind of a big event that happened in the person's life that is highly salient, consequential, maybe a move or something like that. And then typically folks would report that from that point onwards, they've had these experiences kind of be sealed more into their memories. So, Markey, are you aware of any relatives you have who also have H-SAM? No, but at Marquette, when I was working with Dr. Nielsen in their psychology department, she asked a lot of questions about my parents and actually brought my mom in to do some cognitive testing in an interview.
这可能是某人第一次意识到这就是正在发生的事情。或者它可能是指在可能是一个巨大变化的特定事件之后，记忆开始变得非常非常强烈。它可能是创伤性的。它可能只是发生在个人生活中的一件大事，具有高度显著性、后果重大，可能是搬家或类似的事情。然后通常人们会报告说，从那时起，这些体验就被更多地封存在他们的记忆中。所以，马基，你知道你有任何亲戚也拥有 H-SAM 吗？没有，但在马凯特，当我与心理学系的尼尔森 (Nielsen) 博士一起工作时，她问了很多关于我父母的问题，实际上还把我妈妈请来做一些认知测试和采访。
And what we found is that my mom is really good with like verbal recall and she's also good at, she has a very strong autobiographical memory, not as strong as mine, like remembering certain dates. But if you ask her, she could tell you about events where we sat when we were at this concert or, you know, what was going on in our family last Christmas or, you know, whatever it was. my dad was already passed away by the time that we realized I had H. Sam and there was a name to call it. And so he died the same year I found out I had H. Sam, so a couple months before. But what we remember about my father is he had an incredible ability to remember numbers. He knew people's addresses from his childhood, people's phone numbers from his childhood that he didn't need anymore.
我们发现我妈妈非常擅长言语回忆，而且她也很擅长，她有很强的自传体记忆，没有我那么强，比如记住某些日期。但如果你问她，她可以告诉你我们在这次音乐会上坐的位置，或者，你知道，去年圣诞节我们家里发生了什么，或者，你知道，无论是什么。在我意识到我有 H-SAM 并且有一个名字可以称呼它的时候，我爸爸已经去世了。所以他在我发现我有 H-SAM 的同一年去世了，也就是几个月前。但我们对我父亲的记忆是，他拥有记住数字的不可思议的能力。他知道他童年时期的地址，童年时期的电话号码，而他已经不需要这些了。
He had our whole family's social security numbers memorized, you know, that he could just say. And so, you know, he had that. And then my mom had the memory thing. So it's kind of interesting how for me those kind of combined in like a memorization of numbers or an ability to remember numbers like dates. And then also the autobiographical part of it as well. I understand there are some links between H-SAM and. and some mental health conditions. Markey, you've written about the connection between your H-SAM and obsessive-compulsive disorder.
他把我们全家的社保号码都背了下来，你知道，他可以说出来。所以，你知道，他有那个。然后我妈妈有记忆的事情。所以对我来说，这些如何结合在一起，比如对数字的记忆或记住数字（如日期）的能力，这很有趣。还有自传体的那一部分。我了解到 H-SAM 与某些心理健康状况之间存在一些联系。马基，你写过关于你的 H-SAM 与强迫症之间联系的文章。
Can you talk about that? Okay, yeah. So I really feel like my H-SAM and OCD are pretty heavily linked. And it's because any time after I got diagnosed with OCD, people would be like, what are you obsessed with? What are you obsessed with? And I honestly didn't know. I was just like, I have compulsions. and I feel like I have to do things and I have a lot of anxiety and I have a tendency to hoard
你能谈谈这个吗？好的，是的。所以我真的觉得我的 H-SAM 和强迫症联系相当紧密。这是因为在我被诊断出患有强迫症后的任何时候，人们都会问：“你痴迷于什么？你痴迷于什么？”我老实说不知道。我只是觉得我有强迫行为，
things, you know, all things I've been treated for and whatnot. But then as I started working with my, you know, with H-Sam and stuff, I realized my obsession was dates, dates and calendars and my own events in my life because, you know, what it kind of helped me do, or not help me do, but it helped the OCD flourish in a lot of ways when I was younger because I could remember exactly how something happened and then I'd create a ritual to reinforce it. So what would happen was, let's say I wore a particular shirt the day I was taking a math test I was really nervous about. Because of my memory, I could remember, you know, everything I did that day, the shirt I wore, what I ate for breakfast, you know, who I talked to that day. And then my, the part of my brain that
我觉得我必须做一些事情，我有很多焦虑，而且我有囤积东西的倾向，你知道，所有这些我都接受过治疗等等。但后来当我开始与，你知道，H-SAM 等等合作时，我意识到我的痴迷是日期、日期和日历以及我生活中的事件，因为，你知道，它在很大程度上帮助我做到了什么，或者不是帮助我做到，但它在很多方面帮助强迫症在我年轻时蓬勃发展，因为我可以记住某事是如何发生的，然后我会创建一个仪式来加强它。所以会发生的是，假设我在参加一个让我非常紧张的数学考试那天穿了一件特定的衬衫。因为我的记忆，我可以记住，你知道我那天做的所有事情，我穿的衬衫，我早餐吃了什么，你知道，我那天和谁说话。然后我的，我大脑中
had, you know, was responsible for my OCD would be like, all right, well, next time you've got a math test. If you want to get an A, guess who you have to talk to? Guess what you have to eat for breakfast? Guess what you have to wear? And it started reinforcing that. So I think my memory played a large role into creating a lot of rituals that I was kind of slave to for a long, long time. Dr. Yes, is that common among the people you work with? Absolutely. So we see elements of this, perhaps maybe not at the level of a full diagnosis of obsessive compulsive disorder, but certainly obsessive tendencies and obsessions, so the thoughts themselves, that seems to be much more highly represented in the group with H. Sam. And, you know, it's interesting, actually, for me really
负责我强迫症的部分会想，“好吧，下次你有数学考试。如果你想得 A，猜猜你必须和谁说话？猜猜你早餐必须吃什么？猜猜你必须穿什么？”它开始强化这一点。所以我认为我的记忆在创造许多我长期以来一直是其奴隶的仪式方面发挥了重要作用。亚萨博士，这在你共事的人中很常见吗？绝对的。所以我们看到了这些元素的影子，也许没有达到强迫症完全诊断的程度，但当然有强迫倾向和痴迷，也就是思想本身，这在拥有 H-SAM 的群体中似乎表现得更加明显。而且，你知道，实际上对我来说很有趣
to hear Markey speak about it because we've struggled to try to understand the causality chain. In other words, is it that those two are sort of co-occurring conditions and they're sort of feeding off of one another and some individuals maybe to an extent but not others, or is one actually leading to the other? In other words, if there's evidence of obsessions that are related to dates, if that happens in any individual who might otherwise be, you know, perfectly fine, does it lead to this H-Sam condition? And we don't know the answer to that. I don't know if it's going to be that simple or straightforward, to be honest with you. I do think that there are some interesting shared traits and shared mechanisms, especially as Markie was talking about,
听到马基谈论它，因为我们一直在努力试图理解因果链。换句话说，是这二者本质上是共发的状况，它们在某种程度上相互滋养，在某些个体中可能达到一定程度而其他人则不然，还是其中一个实际上导致了另一个？换句话说，如果有与日期相关的痴迷的证据，如果这发生在任何其他情况下可能完全正常的个体身上，它会导致这种 H-SAM 状况吗？我们不知道答案。老实说，我不知道它是否会那么简单或直接。我确实认为有一些有趣的共同特征和共同机制，就像马基刚才谈到的那样，
obsessing over dates, and they become much more important, much more consequential, because you see the value. That kind of feed-forward cycle can precipitate the condition, can perhaps lead to higher levels of anxiety and higher levels of OCD, but also can make the H-SAM abilities much more reinforceable. So if you're practicing this often and thinking about it often, you can imagine, just like anything else, you're going to get better at it. One thing that Mark you mentioned earlier, which I love because I've heard it now from a number of our volunteers, is the notion of going back a year. So saying, you know, today is April 16th. What happened on April 16th, 2020? What about 2019?
对日期的痴迷，它们变得更加重要，后果更严重，因为你看到了价值。那种正反馈循环可以诱发这种状况，可能会导致更高水平的焦虑和更高水平的强迫症，但也可以使 H-SAM 能力更容易被强化。所以如果你经常练习并且经常思考它，你可以想象，就像其他任何事情一样，你会变得更好。马基刚才提到的一件事，我很喜欢，因为我现在已经从我们的许多志愿者那里听到了，那就是回到一年前的概念。所以说，你知道，今天是 4 月 16 日。2020 年 4 月 16 日发生了什么？2019 年呢？
What about 2018? And we'll often hear that. And it seems like, you know, kind of a strange thing, maybe, but it is an archival mechanism. It's a way to kind of build a record of the past day by day. So we're still trying to figure out what those organizational schemes might look like, but I'm fascinated that this game of going back a year is actually something that was commonly shared across a number of volunteers that we've spoken to. You were both quoted in a Wall Street Journal article last summer about how the COVID lockdowns were affecting people's memory. And as you talked about this, going back a year, going back a year and going back a year, what has the lockdown done to the memories of people
2018 年呢？我们经常听到这个。这看起来可能是一个奇怪的事情，但它是一种档案机制。这是一种逐日建立过去记录的方法。所以我们仍在试图弄清楚这些组织方案可能是什么样的，但我很着迷的是，这种回到一年的游戏实际上是我们交谈过的许多志愿者共同分享的东西。去年夏天，你们俩都在《华尔街日报》的一篇文章中被引用，谈到新冠疫情封锁如何影响人们的记忆。当你们谈论这个时，回到一年前，回到一年前，再回到一年前，封锁对拥有 H-SAM 的人的记忆造成了什么影响？
with H. Sam? So if you're directing this at me, I can tell you just in generalities. And what we have heard from some of our volunteers is that they don't feel that their track record, their memory of the past is as good as it was. Because there's not enough events and not enough things happening, not enough salient dates with real occurrences to be able to gravitate to. But we've heard the same thing also from everybody else. So I don't think it's just limited to H-SAM. I think it really is kind of almost like a memory fog that we're all experiencing because it has been so monotonous and we've all been stuck at home and locked down.
所以如果你是在对我说，我可以泛泛而谈。我们从一些志愿者那里听到的是，他们觉得他们过去的轨道记录和记忆不像以前那么好了。因为没有足够的事件，没有足够的事情发生，没有足够的带有真实事件的显著日期来吸引他们。但我们也从其他人那里听到了同样的事情。所以我不认为这仅限于 H-SAM。我认为这实际上几乎就像是我们所有人都在经历的记忆迷雾，因为它是如此单调，我们都被困在家里并被封锁了。
There hasn't been enough experiences with novelty in them that our memory systems kind of gravitate to and say, this is important, I need to store that for later use. But I'd love to hear from Marky what her feelings have been also. Yeah, I would too. Is it disconcerting that you don't have these hooks to grab onto? Yeah, and it's, I've really found it's just a portion of lockdown. And maybe it's because I live in Alabama, so it looks a little different here. But, you know, last March is really vivid. Last March when, you know, I remember like, you know, everything shutting down and all all of like how that was playing out.
没有足够的新奇体验供我们的记忆系统所吸引并说，“这很重要，我需要把它存起来以后用。”但我很想听听马基的感受。是的，我也想知道。没有这些可以抓住的钩子，是不是让人感到不安？是的，而且我真的发现这只是封锁的一部分。也许是因为我住在阿拉巴马州，所以这里的风景看起来有点不同。但是，你知道，去年的三月非常生动。去年的三月，当，你知道，我记得就像，你知道，一切都关门了以及所有这一切是如何展开的。
And like my last, the last day, like the day we found out that like the university, Auburn University was going to shut down like March 13th, right? That was that Friday. And then that Sunday on the 15th, all staff got an email like, hey, we're going to start doing some remote work. And we're like, whoa, whoa, whoa, what's happening? And I remember, you know, on the 11th that Wednesday, I was seeing the movie Emma about the Jane Austen novel.
就像我的最后一天，就像我们发现奥本大学将要关门的那一天，3 月 13 日，对吧？那是星期五。然后那个周日，也就是 15 日，所有员工都收到了一封电子邮件，说：“嘿，我们将开始进行一些远程工作。”我们就像，“哇，哇，哇，怎么了？”我记得，你知道，在 11 日那个周三，我在看根据简·奥斯汀小说改编的电影《艾玛》(Emma)。
And it was, you know, I didn't know it was the last time I'd be sitting in a movie theater for a really long time. And all of a sudden, my phone just starts buzzing and buzzing. And I was like, what's going on? And the NBA is getting canceled. March Madness is getting canceled. And it was like, what's happening? But man, I have to tell you, April is blurry. April is is gone.
那是，你知道，我不知道那是我很长一段时间以来最后一次坐在电影院里。突然之间，我的手机开始嗡嗡作响。我心想：“怎么回事？”NBA 被取消了。疯狂三月被取消了。就像，“怎么回事？”但是天哪，我必须告诉你，四月是一片模糊。四月已经消失了。
Like it's, I remember Easter, because we did like a family Zoom Easter. My boyfriend and I and then my two friends that are back in Indiana, we did. We played ticket to ride virtually together one weekend, and that'll be a year ago on this coming Sunday. So I remember that. But there's like very few events because when you're working from home and you're not, and you're not even leaving your apartment, you know, for anything besides going to the grocery store, it's, it was murky.
就像，我记得复活节，因为我们办了一个家庭 Zoom 复活节。我和我的男朋友，然后是我在印第安纳州的两个朋友，我们做了。我们在一个周末一起虚拟玩了“车票之旅”(Ticket to Ride)，算下来离现在正好是一年前的这个周日。所以我记得那个。但几乎没有什么活动，因为当你呆在家里工作，甚至除了去杂货店之外哪里都不去时，你知道，这有点阴暗模糊。
But when it came back was Memorial Day weekend. Yeah, Memorial Day weekend of last year with not only having a holiday. and things like that, but then the killing of George Floyd happened. And so that is, like, I think a big event for me that kind of like started the H-SAM again of like, okay, we're back. Like, and events started happening. Dr. Yasser, what is the practical application of your work in this area? I mentioned in the intro in looking at Alzheimer's, kind of the opposite where people
但当它卷土重来时，正好赶上阵亡将士纪念日周末。是的，去年阵亡将士纪念日周末不仅迎来了假期，而且还发生了乔治·弗洛伊德被谋杀的事件。所以，我认为这是一个重大事件，对我来说，它再次拉开了超常自传体记忆（H-SAM）的序幕，就好像是，好吧，我们回来了。事件开始发生了。亚塞尔博士，您的这项工作在这个领域的实际应用是什么？我在引言中提到过，在研究阿尔茨海默病时，这有点像反其道而行之，人们
lose their autobiographical memory. Is this going to help with that? We hope so. And in particular, some of our colleagues have also kind of identified what we think is the opposite scheme, what they call S-dam or severely deficient autobiographical memory. So this is my colleague Brian Levine and his laboratory have identified individuals who have very, very fuzzy records of the past. Now, they still do okay on other memory tests and okay in other facets of life. And they're not Alzheimer's patients or anything like that, but their record. of the past is not as rich as most of us would have.
失去了他们的自传体记忆。这会对解决这个问题有帮助吗？我们希望如此。特别的是，我们的一些同事也确定了我们认为相反的模式，他们称之为 S-DAM，即严重缺陷型自传体记忆。这是我的同事布莱恩·莱文（Brian Levine）和他的实验室确立的，他们发现了一些对过去只有非常、非常模糊记忆的个体。现在，他们在其他记忆测试中表现依然不错，在生活的其他方面也过得去。他们不是阿尔茨海默病患者或类似的人，但他们对过去的记忆不像我们大多数人那样丰富。
So it seems like there is sort of a continuum or maybe a bell-shaped curve with two extremes here. And understanding the extremes always informs us about the process and the mechanism. When the condition was first identified, Dr. McGaugh, I think, is quoted, as saying this might have us, you know, rewrite the textbooks and really rethink the way we think about memory, we've always grown in the field to think that memory is adaptive because it doesn't store everything. It leaves a lot out and really focuses on things that can be used for generalizable knowledge. And in fact, there are lots of examples about how damaging it would be if we tried to store everything because we would not be able to generalize.
所以这看起来像是一个连续体，或者可能是一个带有两个极端的钟形曲线。理解极端情况总能让我们深入了解其过程和机制。麦高（McGough）博士在这一病症最初被识别时，曾被引述说，这可能会让我们重写教科书，并真正重新思考我们对记忆的看法。我们在该领域一直以来的成长认知是，记忆具有适应性，因为它不会存储所有东西。它遗漏了很多内容，并真正专注于可用于总结出普遍知识的事物。事实上，有很多例子表明，如果我们试图存储一切将是多么具有破坏性，因为那样我们将无法进行概括。
However, seeing and the experience of those with age, Sam suggests otherwise. suggest that maybe we miss something in that original assessment, and that it is possible to generalize flexibly and be able to apply knowledge and have an exceptional track record of the past. So from a fundamental neuroscience perspective alone, it's really informative to try to understand that condition. And, of course, once you understand the machine and how it works, you can start to understand also how it breaks down.
然而，超常自传体记忆（H-SAM）患者的所见所感却表明情况并非如此。这表明我们可能在最初的评估中漏掉了一些东西，并且有可能灵活地概括并应用知识，同时在过去拥有非凡的记忆轨迹。因此，仅从基础神经科学的角度来看，试图理解这种病症真的很有启发性。当然，一旦你了解了这个机器及其运作方式，你就可以开始了解它是如何发生故障的。
So I do think there's going to be a lot of applicability to conditions where we have memory loss, not just Alzheimer's disease, but a variety of different neuropsychiatric illnesses as well. So, Markey, I'm guessing that as a result of your work with Dr. Yass's lab, that you were able to meet other people like yourself with H. Sam. What was that like to finally meet somebody who has a memory like yours? I would say that the first meeting was very dramatic because 60 Minutes Australia made it very dramatic.
因此，我认为这将对许多伴随记忆丧失的病症有很大的应用价值，不仅是阿尔茨海默病，还包括各种不同的神经精神疾病。所以，玛基（Markey），我猜由于你在亚塞尔博士实验室的工作，你得以结识了其他像你一样患有H-SAM的人。终于见到一个拥有和你一样记忆的人，那是一种什么样的体验？我想说，第一次见面非常戏剧化，因为澳大利亚60分钟节目把它拍得非常戏剧化。
But Dr. Yes is like, yeah, I think I've seen this video. But anyway. What did they do? Oh, my gosh. So I met Becky, who is a lovely, lovely woman from Australia, from, I believe, Queensland, Australia that has H.SAM as well. And 60 Minutes Australia wanted to do a segment on her as being, at the time, at least, the only Australian and maybe still the only Australian with H-Sam. And her dream was to meet another person with H-Sam.
但亚塞尔博士说，是的，我想我见过这个视频。但无论如何。他们做了什么？哦，天哪。我遇到了贝基（Becky），她是一位非常、非常可爱的澳大利亚女士，据我所知来自澳大利亚昆士兰州，她也患有H-SAM。澳大利亚60分钟节目想为她做一个专题节目，因为当时（至少在当时）她是唯一一个、也许现在仍然是唯一一个患有H-SAM的澳大利亚人。她的梦想就是结识另一个患有H-SAM的人。
So they looked at kind of the prospective folks and noticed I was the closest one to her age and also a girl. And so, you know, they thought it'd be good for us to meet. So 60 minutes and all their team flew my mom and I out to Los Angeles and we got to meet Becky. And they did this very dramatic like walk-in scene of like me standing in a courtyard and like her walking in, like it was the bachelor or something. And then also the hilarious part too is like,
所以他们查看了潜在的人选名单，发现我是最接近她年龄的人，而且也是个女孩。所以他们觉得让我们见面会很不错。因此，60分钟节目的整个团队安排我和妈妈飞往洛杉矶，我们见到了贝基。他们安排了一个非常戏剧化的进场场景，比如我站在一个庭院里，然后她走进来，就像在演《单身汉》或者类似节目一样。而且，搞笑的部分还在于，
and anyone listening to this who has filmed a TV show before will know this, but they had to do that take like 10 times. And so, you know, I met her for the first time once, but I had to act as like surprised and shocked and in awe as like I did the first time. And you know, Becky and I aren't TV actresses here. Like we're not, we're not trying to get big or anything. So it was just kind of funny as they're like, all right, act surprise again. And we're like, okay.
任何听这个节目并且以前拍过电视节目的人都会知道这一点，他们不得不把那个镜头拍了大概10次。所以，你知道，我第一次见到她其实只有一次，但我必须表现得像第一次那样惊讶、震惊和敬畏。而且你知道，我和贝基又不是电视女演员。我们不是，我们不是为了成名什么的。所以当他们说“好的，再表现得惊讶一次”时，这就显得有点好笑了，我们就说，好吧。
So, you know, it was kind of funny. But Becky and I did get to develop a relationship and become friends. And that was the actual meaningful part. And that was the first time I had met anyone. The second time was when I was doing a segment for Scientific American and they filmed us in New York City when I was a graduate student back in 2017. and I got to meet Joey and Nicole, who are both East Coasters with H-Sam. And so meeting them was really awesome too.
所以，你知道，这有点搞笑。但我和贝基确实建立起了联系，成为了朋友。那才是真正有意义的部分。那是我第一次见到任何人。第二次是当我为《科学美国人》杂志做一个专题节目时，2017年我在读研究生的时候，他们在纽约市拍摄了我们，我有机会见到了乔伊（Joey）和妮可（Nicole），他们都是拥有H-SAM的东海岸人。所以见到他们也真的很棒。
They didn't do the dramatic meet scene. They kind of just had us all like in a, you know, in kind of a panel kind of mode and stuff like that. But it's really cool to meet others with H-Sam because you can talk about like similar experiences that you have because of your H-Sam that other people may not experience. You can make jokes with them too, you know, date-related jokes. that are super fun. And just, again, just relate to, you know, we all have friends that we relate to for certain things, right? Like if me and a friend are really into at the NFL, you know, we're going to connect over that. But there's only a handful of people in the world that you can connect over this with. And so it's really special when you get to meet. Dr. Yes, where is this research going next?
他们没有搞那种戏剧性的见面场景。他们只是把我们所有人安排在，你知道的，某种小组讨论的模式里等等。但是能遇到其他拥有H-SAM的人真的很酷，因为你可以谈论由于你的H-SAM而拥有的、其他人可能不会经历的相似经历。你也可以和他们开玩笑，你知道，跟日期相关的玩笑，超级有趣。而且再次强调，这只是能产生共鸣，你知道，我们都有在某些事情上能产生共鸣的朋友，对吧？就像如果我和一个朋友都很迷NFL，你知道的，我们就会因此产生连接。但世界上只有少数几个人能就这个话题与你产生连接。所以当你能遇到这样的人时，真的很特别。亚塞尔博士，这项研究接下来将走向何方？
What's the big question you would still like to answer? So there's a few avenues that we're pursuing. One is that we would like to use more sort of validated tests to really fully assess the extent of H-SAM and be able to cater to different ranges of experiences in different ages, as Markey said. So we've developed a couple of tools that we're able to use in children and adolescents that are not so time and era sensitive. We've developed another one that is tapping into different areas of expertise, and we're just in the process of validates. those tests and making sure that they are reproducible and reliable and using them on a large enough data set so we can get a better feel for the prevalence of H-SAM. Second, we would like to keep experimenting with the neurobiology and really try to understand how is it that brains might be wired a little bit differently or have developed in a slightly different way to allow for these superior abilities to manifest. And that involves brain imaging studies, which we're embarking on. And then the third piece is the genetics and trying to really figure out if there is a heritable pattern
你最想回答的重大问题是什么？所以我们正在探索几个途径。其一是，我们希望使用更多经过验证的测试来全面评估H-SAM的程度，并能够像玛基所说的那样，迎合不同年龄段的不同经历范围。因此，我们开发了一些可以在儿童和青少年身上使用的工具，这些工具对时间和年代不那么敏感。我们开发了另一种工具，它能触及不同的专业领域，我们正处于验证这些测试的过程中，以确保它们具有可再现性和可靠性，并将其应用于足够大的数据集，以便我们能够更好地了解H-SAM的患病率。其次，我们希望继续对神经生物学进行实验，并真正试图了解大脑是如何被连接得有些不同，或者以稍微不同的方式发育，从而使这些超群的能力得以显现。这涉及到我们正在着手开展的大脑成像研究。第三部分是遗传学，试图真正弄清楚是否存在一种可遗传的模式，
and trying to figure out if there's something about gene environment interactions, perhaps in the earliest ages and during childhood and adolescents that allow for this to fully kind of come through. So those are, I think, the three areas that we're mostly concerned with right now. And we're expanding to work with some collaborators who really do exceptional work in these areas to have a better handle on it. Last question, to Markey, are you glad you have this ability or would you give it up? That's a hard question. It's really a hard one. And the answer lies somewhere in the middle. And that's what I've had to come to in the choices I've had to make. So when I found out that I had obsessive disorder, you know, I had the opportunity to start getting
并试图弄清楚基因与环境的相互作用是否存在某种规律，也许在最早的年龄段以及儿童和青少年时期，使这种能力得以完全展现。所以，我认为这是我们目前最关注的三个领域。我们正在扩大合作，与在这些领域做出杰出贡献的一些合作者一起工作，以便更好地掌控它。最后一个问题，问玛基，你高兴拥有这种能力，还是愿意放弃它？这是一个很难的问题。这确实是一个难题。答案介于两者之间。这也是我在必须做出的选择中不得不接受的结果。所以当我发现自己患有强迫症时，你知道，我开始有机会接受
treatments or getting medicated. And when I started getting medicated, my ability to recall as fast and quick and almost even sometimes accurately as I could started to go away. And so, you know, I had to end up making the choice. Do I want to live with OCD and H-SAM or do I want to not really live with a muted version of OCD and a muted version of H-SAM? And I chose living with a muted version because I'm a full functioning human being with dimensions to my wellness and to my life. And I love having H-SAM and the ability to go back in the past and recall. call and remember and cherish and savor those memories is so important to me. But it can't get in the way of the rest of my life in my future. It's kind of like picking between the past and the future.
治疗或服药。当我开始接受药物治疗时，我回忆的速度、敏捷度甚至有时准确度开始下降。所以，你知道，我最终不得不做出选择。我是想带着强迫症和H-SAM生活，还是想过一种削弱版强迫症和削弱版H-SAM的生活？我选择了过一种削弱版的生活，因为我是一个功能健全的人，我的健康和生活中都有不同的维度。我喜欢拥有H-SAM，喜欢那种能够回到过去、回忆、铭记、珍视和品味那些记忆的能力，这对我很重要。但它不能妨碍我生活的其余部分和未来。这有点像在过去和未来之间做选择。
And it's a hard choice. But, you know, I still have the ability. Could it be, again, more entertaining on TV shows if I stopped my treatment for OCD? Maybe, yeah. But is it worth it? It's not. And so it's kind of hard, but I'm glad I'm at where I'm at now with balance. Thank you both for joining us today. It's been a pleasure talking to you. I really appreciate you taking the time and telling us personal stories. Thank you. Thank you for having us. Thank you so much, Kim. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology at www.combeingof Psychology.org or on Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. And please leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us
这是一个艰难的选择。但是，你知道，我仍然拥有这种能力。如果我停止治疗强迫症，在电视节目上会不会再次更有娱乐性？也许吧。但这值得吗？不值得。所以这有点难，但我很高兴我现在达到了平衡的状态。感谢两位今天做客我们的节目。与你们交谈非常愉快。非常感谢你们抽出时间并分享个人的故事。谢谢。谢谢你们邀请我们。非常感谢，金。您可以在 www.findingpsychology.org 或 Apple、Stitcher 以及您获取播客的任何地方找到往期的《心理学访谈》节目。请给我们留下评价。如果您对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，可以发送电子邮件给我们
at Speaking of Psychology at APA.org. That's Speaking of Psychology, all one word, at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condihan. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. Do you remember where you were on April 10th, 1999?
邮箱地址是 Speaking of Psychology at APA.org。也就是 Speaking of Psychology，所有单词连在一起，在 APA.org。本期《心理学访谈》由李·维纳曼（Lee Weinerman）制作。我们的音频编辑是克里斯·康迪汉（Chris Condihan）。谢谢收听。我是美国心理学会的金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。你还记得1999年4月10你在哪里吗？
What day of the week was it? No, no, no, we were supposed to answer that. I'm so sorry. Sorry. Sorry. I was just, my bad. my bad. I was just like, I was four. I thought it was a question, too. No, this is the intro. This is the intro. I'm trying to.
那天是星期几？不，不，不，我们本该回答那个问题的。非常抱歉。抱歉。抱歉。我只是，我的错。我的错。我只是觉得，我当时四岁。我以为那也是个问题。不，这是引言。这是引言。我在试着。
My bad, my bad, my bad. Trying to bring people in. All right. Okay, Chris, Chris, never mind all that. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我的错，我的错，我的错。试着把大家带入情境。好了。好吧，克里斯，克里斯，别管那些了。这期节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。